two police officers pinned down jenny
valdo de jesus santos a black man they
say was resisting arrest
they then trap him inside the smoked
filled trunk of their police car
look at the man there oh my god they're
killing him inside the car says one
witness
video of the incident went viral on
social media
protests have been held in his home town
of ambalba in northeast in brazil and
shock and outrage expressed across the
country
for years human rights activists have
accused police in brazil of
discrimination brutality and excessive
force
on tuesday the day before santos died
dozens of people were shot dead during a
police raid on a criminal gang in rio de
janeiro
yes another massacre in a favela it's
truly shocking we cannot allow it to be
normal that the state enters a favela
and leaves with 20 or more dead
relatives of santos say he was unarmed
and suffering from heart problems and
schizophrenia the federal highway police
have opened an investigation into his
death in a statement they said santos
was actively resisting the officers who
pulled him over they immobilized him
then used instruments of lesser
offensive potential to contain him
santos was taken to hospital doctors say
he was dead when he arrived at the
emergency room the officers involved
have been suspended but many in brazil
fear this may be another example of
institutional brutality and racism
within the police
victoria gatenby al jazeera